these scenes are sure to irritate the
Turkish government protesters walk
through the book fair in Istanbul they
demand freedom for journalists and
criticize the government for jailing
writers as terrorists visitors at the
fair applaud their demonstration as
Allah Erewhon is a journalist who has
been imprisoned for months without
charge but accused of inciting terrorism
she is one of some 150 authors who have
been arrested since the failed coup in
July at this fair many stand in
solidarity including borhan so mez a
human rights lawyer and writer he has
been imprisoned several times if you say
turkey is so different i would say
turkey always been like this since I was
born maybe sometimes is it worse or
maybe much worse here the crisis seems
far removed a destination for families
crowds bustle throughout the fair as
publishers offer bargain prices the
books of Exile journalists such as Y and
under can also be found though it
doesn't look like it to sell such books
in Turkey is risky this is a
thirty-five-year-old publishing house so
we have been true a coup changing
government's economic crises so being a
publisher in Turkey if you're not just a
new baby publishing house you have to be
ready to cope with all kinds of
oppression within this charged
atmosphere Germany is a guest of honor
at the book fair for four days writers
from both countries need to talk about
literature but also to discuss the
threats to free speech a balancing act
for organizers of the German
contribution they think politicians have
a role to play many things have happened
now because people have been watching
and not acting now it seems the
government can do anything there is no
real resistance beat up stuff missing
of course we must also make it clear
with the federal government and the EU
Commission that a policy of standing by
and doing nothing in such situations is
wrong get notified schism moretz rinka
is a writer and playwright from Berlin
he's in Turkey quite often he believes
that talking about the issues must
continue there are so many people who
yearn for Europe and they are more
distant than ever from the continent and
these people have to be given the hope
that we will not fail them Zenith aura
has been a journalist for more than 40
years and now works for the opposition
newspaper jamui it she's disappointed
with the west and hurt that young people
are leaving the country but she's not
giving up after a certain age you're not
afraid if you know that you're innocent
you are not afraid if you are cautious
of what you're doing you have to go on
doing it there are courageous
journalists like her who need support in
the fight for freedom of expression